redfall is the latest shooter coming
from Arcane Austin the same branch of
Arcane Studios responsible for 2017's
prey redfull was first announced at E3
2021 with a cinematic trailer showcasing
a cast of Heroes with special powers
fighting off against vampires however
since then we've learned far more this
is everything we know so far about
redfall
redfall is set in the fictional titular
Island and city of redfall set in
Massachusetts the island has come under
siege by an army of vampires the
vampires are related to the corporation
Avon Therapeutics whose slogan is making
tomorrow last longer and who as the
slogan would imply are seeking
immortality at some point they told a
girl that a blood could cure people of
sickness and death however it seems that
they're testing on her and potentially
other subjects are what led to the
creation and outbreak of these vampires
that Army of the undead has created an
Endless Night by blocking out the Sun
and also prevented any and all Escape by
cutting the island off from the rest of
the world some of the humans who are
still alive have joined a cult devoted
to sacrificing everyone to the vampires
viewing these vampires as Gods created
by science these vampires include the
likes of the hollow man bloody Tom Mom
miss whisper and the black Sun are the
humans are struggling to find a way to
survive the nightmare stop these Godlike
beings and take back redfall you fall
into the latter Camp playing as one of
four survivors
there's cryptozoologist and inventor
davinder krausley davinder wrote a book
called like a Mothman to the flame and
wants to show the worlds that the
imaginary isn't so far from the real as
his parents didn't approve of his career
choice and with limited resources he's
created all of his own equipment which
you'll be able to use in the game
there's combat engineer Remy De la Rosa
Remy has a robot cohort named briben and
at one point she was in the middle of
organizing various survivors for
evacuation when either a vampire or
cultist snuck in thanks to an update
she's just installed on briben briban
fired on the enemy and saved her life
she's now more determined than ever to
utilize her skills and briben to save
others there's ex-military Sharpshooter
Jacob Boya after his service Jacob
turned to a life of contract work on one
such job for Bellwether Protection
Services Jacob was sent to Avon to
recover something when his team was
ambushed by one of the vampire guards
for some unknown reason the vampire left
him with a vampiric eye and now a
spectral Raven never leaves his side and
finally there's biomedical engineer
student Leila Ellison Layla was
interning at an even research facility
when something went wrong and left her
with telekinetic abilities her and her
ex-boyfriend were on their way back from
seeing a movie when they were ambushed
by vampires and cultists looking to
capture her and she used her powers to
fight back
you'll be able to choose to play as one
of these specific Heroes throughout the
duration of the game's story driven
campaign as their backgrounds indicate
they each have their own unique
abilities and skills that completely
change the way they play Layla has a
focus on utilizing her telekinetic
skills Jacob on sniping and Gunplay Remy
on her robot buddy briben cool she'll
use to distract or help her to fight
enemies and davinder on the various
equipment he's invented redfull can be
tackled Solo or cooperatively with up to
four total players notably if you do
choose to play solo the other characters
aren't going to be controlled by Bots
and you truly will be alone if you do
choose to play with friends the game
doesn't rebalance the combat so if one
character is a say level 20 and the
other level 5 the lower level character
may have a pretty hard time missions can
be approached in a multitude of ways
depending on your personal gameplay
style parts of this will have to do with
which character you choose as each of
them have such unique ability is both
useful Solo or if you're playing Co-op
you can approach encounters from more of
a stealth standpoint and distract
enemies to stack the odds in your favor
or even skip certain counters or you can
of course go in guns blazing if you so
choose from various previews it seems
like playing the game solo can be an
intense and at times frightening
experience whereas playing with a group
of friends completely changes the feel
to a fun romp with your buddies tag
teaming abilities and stomping through
vampires each character has a skill tree
where in standard skill tree fashion you
can unlock progressively more powerful
skills with skill points you'll obtain
however there is no respect option so
once you make a choice on your skill
tree you are stuck with it many of these
choices such as not being able to
respect or not rebalancing gameplay
during Co-op Arcane feels our quality of
life elements that have been added to
games over the years that actually hurt
the overall experience of playing the
game game the arsenal of weapons you
have at your disposal includes both
military gear and vampire slaying
inventions unique to the world you'll
also unlock and find various vampire
Stakes you can attach to your weapons
redfall is a looter shooter similar to
Borderlands with all of the loot
color-coded into tears by its Rarity and
power the setting of the game is open
world with Arcane noting that they've
packed in details and environmental
storytelling throughout areas you'll be
able to explore on the island include a
haunted forest formerly bustling
downtown and decimated seaside boardwalk
as you aren't the only Survivor that
means there are safe areas and bases
such as a fire station these bases serve
as hubs where you'll be able to rest
resupply and get New Missions from other
survivors as the game is open world that
means you'll be getting both story
missions and optional side missions some
of these side missions might come in the
form of encounters you'll come across
such as a brewery that's Fallen under
cultist control or otherworldly psychic
spaces one such type of encounter
includes vampire nests which are
procedurally generated so the space and
layout within change each time you enter
one to destroy an S you'll find a
physical heart within typically guarded
by a whole lot of vampires you'll need
to destroy another side mission includes
taking back the neighborhoods of redfall
by defeating the vampire controlling the
neighborhood you'll reclaim it and make
exploring just that little bit safer
Arcane has gone to Great Lengths to try
and make the open world of redfull feel
meaningful so players will enjoy
exploring its many locations redfall
will be released May 2nd 2023 for both
PC and Xbox series X and S for 69.99 it
will also be available on Game Pass
players on Game Pass can upgrade to the
bike back digital Edition for 29.99
which otherwise costs it's 99.99 by
pre-ordering redfall or playing on Game
Pass players will receive the Vampire
Hunter pack which includes a grim tied
shotgun polar vortex multi-weapon skin
and blood ravager stake weapon
attachment the bike back digital Edition
includes a throwback outfit pack redfall
hero pass to players two future Heroes a
laser beam multi-weapon skin and
tactical knife stake weapon attachment
what character do you see yourself
playing as in redfall and do you see
yourself tackling it Solo or with a
group of friends let us know in the
comments below and we'll see you next
time
thank you
so uh that was fun right